Yeah. Would you believe in a religion
with corrupted scripture?
>> No, I wouldn't. Cuz uh it's like the
same case for the Bible. It's corrupted,
>> right? So you wouldn't believe in a
religion with corrupted scripture for
what reason?
>> Because I wouldn't think that if
something is preserved, then it would be
from God if it's not preserved.
>> Okay. Thank you. So, and that would make
it untrustworthy. Correct.
>> Well, I mean, in total, I'm sure,
>> right? Cool. So, how many sets of
scriptures was revealed in your
religion? You mean like the the
>> No. How many sets of scriptures? Like
how many scriptures were revealed to
prophets? Revelation revealed to
prophets, right? So you have the Quran,
that's one set, right? That's revealed
to Muhammad. It got compiled. Uh what
other sets do you have?
>> Well, if you're just talking about
mainly about like the the Torah and the
Gospel, we believe that those are three
in total.
>> Okay. Uh three other sets, right? Aside
from the Quran,
>> it would be two other sets aside from
the Quran [clears throat] cuz you just
have the Torah and you have
>> So you have the Psalms, you have the
Injil, and you have the Torah. So you
you do you mean three other sets aside
from the Quran?
>> Oh, you're counting the Psalms, too.
Okay. Yeah.
>> I mean, you have to. It's in your book.
Do you you don't believe the Psalms, the
scriptures revealed to David?
>> Well, I mean, I do, but I mean, I hold
the Tamian. Um, I believe that still
like the minority of it is is corrupted.
No, I I know you you probably believe
everything is corrupted other than the
Quran. So I'm asking just is
you don't believe you don't believe you
don't so you don't believe the Torah is
corrupted.
>> No, I believe that there's a minor
corruption, you know, as as
>> that's fine, but that's still an
altering of the scriptures. If there's
no original uncorrupted version of that
book that exists, you believe that that
book was corrupted. It doesn't matter if
you believe that there's bits and Oh,
Logic, you got me. Yeah, thank you. Uh
it doesn't matter if you believe that
there's some truth in the book left. The
book is corrupted. If you're saying the
only thing that is um that's left in
that book is a corrupted version. You're
admitting that that book is corrupted.
>> Yeah. But like the way you're you're
putting it, it's like you're signing
like I I believe the entirety of it or
like the majority of it is corrupt.
>> Well, I'm not asking you that right now.
I'm just I just want to know do you
believe that all of your scriptures
other than the Quran is corrupt? That's
all I'm asking right now.
>> Yeah, in some sense. Yeah, of course. in
some sense.
>> Yeah.
>> So, it's it's either it's either the
scriptures are corrupted or they're not.
Is the Torah corrupted?
>> Yeah, they are. And in the sense that
there's Yeah, in the sense that there's
a minority corruption and not the entire
thing.
>> That's that that's irrelevant. I'm not
asking you that right now. You don't got
to jump to that.
>> I already answered. Yeah, I am.
>> Okay. So, so Okay. So, the answer is
yes. Every other scriptures that was
revealed in your religion other than the
Quran is has been corrupted and altered.
>> Yeah, they've been altered.
>> Okay. Thank you. So the majority of
scriptures revealed in your religion
have been altered.
>> No, I I already told you. If we're
talking about And again, when when you
say majority, you're talking about the
books like as in quantity or you talking
about
>> I'm talking about the scriptures, the
revelation. You just admitted to me that
the majority of the scriptures. Pay
attention. You just said the majority of
scriptures revealed in your religion are
corrupted. Then when I gave you that
back to you, you said no.
>> Yeah. Because again, I'm trying to tell
you like there's I don't know what you
mean by that. So when you're talking
about the scriptures, do you mean the
actual scripture itself or do you mean
the content within the scripture?
>> I'm talking about the actual scripture
in itself. For example, like the Quran,
is any part of the Quran corrupted? Any
part of revelation revealed to Muhammad
uh that got documented and broke and put
down in that book? Is any part of that
corrupted?
>> No.
>> Okay. Can you say that for any other
scriptures that were revealed in in your
Quran? The Torah. Can you say that for
the Torah, the Gospels, the the Psalms?
Can you say that for any other
scriptures you're God revealed?
>> Yeah, I understand what you mean. No,
no, no.
>> Thank you. So, that means that the mass
majority of everything revealed in your
religion is corrupted except for one
thing that came to your prophet
Muhammad. Can we at least agree on that?
Thank Thank you for being honest. All
right, cool. So, you [clears throat]
believe in a religion not only that has
corrupted scripture, but it's full of
corrupted scripture. The majority of
your religion is riddled with corrupted
and altered scripture.
>> And you just said you wouldn't follow a
religion that does that.
>> Yeah. How you defined corrupted because
God logic, you defined it as
>> I define corrupted the way that you just
defined corrupted. You already did it
for me.
>> I never gave a definition. I just told
you what was corrupted and what wasn't.
I never gave you a definition. So I'm
saying the definition that God logic is
going on is altering of a text. So you
can't get an original reading, right? Or
am I incorrect? Brother, can you get the
original reading of the Injil
>> of the Injil? No. Even Even most
scholars agree with that.
>> There it is. There it is. So, is that
altering of the text?
>> Yeah, that is.
>> Okay. Do you believe that the Injil
existed in your book?
>> Yeah.
>> Has it been altered?
>> Okay. Thank you. So, you're literally
defining things that you don't even
stand on. Your religion is full of what
you don't accept.
>> How is that a definition? I'm telling
you what's corrupt and what's not.
That's not a definition. Brother, you
literally just told me your standard of
what it means for something to be
corrupted. Not being able to get the not
being able to Hold on. Hold on. Claiming
that it's altered and not being able to
get the original reading.
>> This is exactly what you guys say about
your in jail in your book. It's been
altered. No one can get the original
reading. So, you just go with whatever
is in line with your Quran.
>> Yeah. Because it's it's demonstrable
that it's been edited. Yeah.
>> Okay. So with that being said, you
follow a religion where majority of your
Islamic scriptures have been corrupted.
Do you agree?
>> Yeah, it's the issue.
>> Thank you. That means that your religion
is untrustworthy. You already admitted
that you wouldn't follow a religion with
corrupted scripture. Now you're saying
you would follow a religion with
corrupted scripture.
>> Yeah. It's because we have a criteria
over it. Our scriptures is the Quran. We
believe these are previous revelations
that are corrupted. They don't take them
as as scripture entirely anymore.
>> All right. So they are corrupted and you
are following a religion with majority
corrupted scripture.
>> Yeah. Again I told you that we already
have a criteria over which is the
>> that's no that's fine but let's conclude
the actual topic. You follow a religion
full of corrupted scripture. The
majority of your religion listen I just
need a yes or no here and then I can go
into what you're saying about how you
know what is and what isn't. The point
is is that we want Muslims to understand
that they follow a religion full of
majority corrupted scripture.
>> Yeah. We don't believe that's our
scripture anymore though because it's
been altered. That's why we have the
criteria.
>> Thank you. So you follow a religion with
majority altered scripture.
>> I just told you it's not our scripture
anymore.
>> Why isn't it your scripture?
>> Because it's been altered.
>> Thank you. So your scripture has been
altered.
>> What? Are you okay? That's the whole
point of why it's not scripture anymore,
>> brother. You're throwing it away because
it's been altered. That means that your
scriptures that were revealed in your
religion are being thrown out because
they've been altered. So the point still
stands. The scriptures revealed in your
religion have been altered. Whether you
say that they're not whether you disown
them or whether you disown them has
nothing to do with whether they were
yours to begin with.
>> They're still yours. You're just
disowning them because they were
altered.
>> No, it does because there's a certain
condition that has to be met for that in
order to be considered scripture.
>> Okay. And the reason why the condition
can't be met is because your scriptures
and your religion have been altered.
>> Yeah. But again, when you're saying my
scripture, my scripture is the Quran.
That's not
>> Okay. So your Okay, let me get you
straight. So your God tells you to
believe in altered scripture.
>> It's he doesn't. It's the point is that
we have a general confirmation. So
brother
>> No, I'm not asking about a general
confirmation at the at this point. I'm
asking you does your God tell you to
believe in altered scripture when he
says you as a Muslim can't be successful
unless you believe in all his books?
>> No. cuz we believe it's a general
statement.
>> Oh, so he's saying so your God is
telling you to generally believe in his
scriptures.
>> No, that's not what it means when you're
talking about a general statement.
That's not the entirety.
>> What?
>> Hey, man. Thanks.
>> I I I just it just to me it just seems
you don't know what a general statement
is.
>> But I do. I just I just
Brother you said your God is telling you
to generally believe in his Listen,
brother. You just said your God is
telling you to generally believe in his
scriptures. Then when I asked you what I
said,
>> okay, so what is your God telling you to
generally believe?
>> I told you that he's telling us that.
Okay, look, we can go to the scripture
to confirm what is in the Quran. That's
the point.
>> No, I didn't ask you that. What is your
in your Quran? Tell me, give me the give
me the Okay, watch this. Give me the
verse where your God is telling you to
generally believe in his books.
>> Yeah, there there's no point of what it
says generally. It's it's inferred.
>> Okay, so give me the verse where it's
inferred.
>> Uh yeah, like for example, I can use
when it says that it's a it's a criteria
over it. Um what is that? It never says
that. So where does it say anywhere? To
generally believe in it. That's what he
asked you. Not to lie and say that it's
not.
>> No, it doesn't. Yeah, it doesn't say
that in those words to generally believe
in it, but I'm saying it's inferred.
>> No, it's not inferred. Oh my goodness.
Go to go to chapter 2 uh four and five.
When he's telling you to believe in the
books and those who who don't believe in
the book are not rightfully guided by
Allah and won't be successful in his
eyes, what is he saying in there?
>> I'm sorry. What was the verse? Chapter
2:es 4 and 5. Your God tells you the
reader, you will not be successful in
his eyes or rightfully guided by him
unless you believe in all of his books.
What is he telling you? Is he telling
you to believe in some of it or all of
it? Because he's talking about the Quran
and all of his books. So what is he what
is he talking about there? Is he is he
saying generally believe in all of his
books or is he telling you to believe in
his books?
>> So this is what I'm reading. It says,
"And those who believe in what was
revealed to you and in what was revealed
before you and certain in the hereafter,
these [clears throat] are upon guidance
from their Lord. These are the
successful."
>> And read the rest.
>> That's it. You said verse four and five.
>> Okay, that's four and five. Perfect. So
now, what does that mean then to you? Is
he telling you to believe in some of it
and you'll be successful and rightfully
got it? Or is he telling you to believe
in his books? Period. We don't get
general from there at all.
>> Yeah. So he can he can still just say
believe in the books. Yeah, that's fine.
That can still be general. So, so he's
generally so so he's generally saying
believe in the Quran, too. Then why does
that
>> because the Quran is in there? It's he's
talking about all of his revelation.
Look, dude, watch this. Read verse four
and just read verse four.
>> And those who believe what was revealed
to you was revealed to hold on. Wait,
stop right there. And those who believe
what was revealed to you. What? What is
that?
>> I mean, that can be anything. That can
be [laughter]
>> Oh my. Get Get him out of here. Get him
out of here.
>> WHY YOU GET HIM OUT OF HERE?
>> HOLD ON. GIVE ME GIVE ME GIVE ME 60
SECONDS.
>> Oh yeah, you going to hear him out. Is
is it is that is that y'all
>> is that is that first is that first
listen is that first part of the
sentence referring to what is being
revealed to Muhammad
>> I can be it's possible it's
>> I'm cool I'm good
>> wait wait wait
>> no no no I'm good to that
>> don't worry about it there's no defeater
bro there's no defeater
>> your Quran is the defeater that's the
defeater your Quran is the defeater
>> your Quran is the defeater y'all just
hey y'all I [laughter]
hate y'all's book, bro. Y'all
[screaming]
hate the Quran, man. Y'all hate Allah.
Y'all hate the Quran. Y'all will make up
whatever you want and say the opposite
of what Allah said. Y'all
>> hate your Quran, man.
>> That is bad, bro.
>> This is insane. Insane.
>> This this this this argument makes them
not know anything on purpose, bro. So
when that mean when the verse is saying
hey believe those who believe in what
was revealed to you and what was
revealed to them they are the ones who
are successful.
Well when it says believe in what was
revealed to them it's talking about
generally but when it's talking about
and believe what is revealed to you that
means wholesale. It's not talking about
generally there
>> all of it. Right. All of it. So they
split and put general in whenever they
feel like it. when the verse don't even
say that at all,
>> man.
>> Like Muslims, bro, y'all gotta leave.
Leave leave Islam, man. This this if you
got to do your book like this, bro,
>> I blame Ramadan.
>> My goodness.
>> Can you get 6205?
>> Would you believe in a religion with
corrupted scripture?
>> No.
>> Are you a Muslim?
>> Yes.
>> Do you believe that Allah revealed the
Torah?
>> Yeah, I do. Can you open up 625?
>> Nope. Not at this moment. Did the Torah
get corrupted?
>> Yes.
>> Did Allah reveal the angel in the
Psalms?
>> Yes. Open 625. You will see it.
>> Did they get corrupted?
>> Yes. 625.
>> 625.
>> Yeah.
>> What about 562?
>> Open 625 and you will see it.
>> Why?
>> Let the people see.
>> You just asked me a question.
>> So, what does 625 have to do with what
I'm asking you?
>> It has to do with the Torah.
>> With the what?
>> With the gospel. With the
>> What does it have to do with it?
>> You will see. Open it, man.
>> I'll see. All right. Usama, how you
doing?
>> I'm good. Can you hear me?
>> Yes. Are you a Muslim?
>> Yes, I am.
>> Awesome. Up to the stage, my friend.
Would you trust a religion with
corrupted scripture?
>> No. No.
>> All right. Do you believe Allah revealed
the Quran?
>> Say that again.
>> Do you believe that Allah revealed the
Torah?
>> Yes.
>> Do the Torah get corrupted
>> by people? Yes.
>> Okay. Uh, same with the angel and the
Psalms, the Zabore. You believe that
Allah revealed them and they got
corrupted?
>> Some of Not all of them. Some of them
have been changed and corrupted.
>> So the Torah, the Psalms, the Gospel,
they've been corrupted. The go. Yeah.
>> Okay. So, the Torah, the Psalms, and the
Gospel, these are revelations of Allah
that got corrupted by men.
>> Yes.
>> That's why God sent Muhammad with the
last book that never been corrupted.
>> Okay.
>> Same as happened with the when God sent
Jesus for the Jews because it been uh
changed.
>> Gotcha. Gotcha. Sounds good. Okay. So,
it sounds like three scriptures within
Islam out of four. You got the Torah,
Psalms, Gospel, Quran. Three scriptures
out of four got corrupted.
>> Yeah.
>> That means that Islam is not trustworthy
because it's full of corrupted
scripture.
>> But the Quran haven't been uh corrupted.
>> Yeah, but the Torah has according to
you. I said, "Yeah, but the Torah,
Gospel, and the Psalms have been
corrupted within Islam." So, your
religion has corrupted scripture.
>> No, it does not. It tells you that what
it tells you that other religions have
been corrupted and he came to correct
them and tells you that they are being
corrupted.
>> So Allah told you from the Quran that
his previous scriptures within the
religion of Islam have been corrupted.
Correct?
>> Yes.
>> So you have a religion full of corrupted
scripture.
>> No, I have a religion that tells you
that man change his own scripture. Yes.
>> So you have a religion full of corrupted
scripture?
>> No.
>> Is the Torah an Islamic book?
>> Is a book of God.
>> So is it a book of Islam?
>> Technically yes. But it it meant uh yes.
>> Okay. The Psalms and the Gospel. Are
those books of Islam?
>> Not the Gospel. But the original Bible
is the Gospel.
>> I'm asking about the So Allah didn't
reveal the gospel.
>> Yeah. The Gospel. Yeah. I thought you
saying something else. Yeah. The Gospel.
So, the Psalm and the Gospel are books
of Islam, correct?
>> Yes.
>> Did these books of Islam get corrupted?
>> Well, let me ask you, who wrote the
Gospel? Did Jesus wrote it?
>> We can get to that in a second.
Actually, that's a good question.
>> Yes.
>> Uh, and I we going to put that on the
side. We could get to that in a second.
Okay. So, just really quick with the
with the question at hand. The Torah,
the Psalm, the Gospel, these are Islamic
books. And you believe
>> Abrahamic Abrahamic's books. Yes.
Islamic, right? Okay. And you believe
that three of these Islamic books got
corrupted. Correct.
>> Yes.
>> So it's full of corrupted scripture. It
has three corrupted scriptures at least.
Right.
>> The first three. Okay. Let's we have the
Bible came with Jesus for what?
>> Please don't talk about. Do you believe
the Bible is the gospel Allah revealed?
>> Yeah. So when God sent Jesus with the
gospel for the Jew, right? and it's been
changed. And then God sent the last
prophet Muhammad with the with the
Quran.
>> I know what you believe. I know I know
what you believe. You don't you don't
have to give me like the the lesson on
what you believe in Islam. I know what
you believe.
>> I'm just telling you the the answering
the question with the
>> You're not answering the you you
literally didn't answer the question.
You went and started telling me the
story of Islam. The question is, so
Islam has three corrupted scriptures at
least. Correct. That was the question.
>> Okay. Yes.
>> Okay. So, since Islam has corrupted
scripture, then it's not trustworthy.
Remember, you said you would not trust a
religion that has corrupted scripture.
You just said Islam has at least three
corrupted scriptures.
>> Yes.
>> So, you shouldn't trust Islam.
>> I trust the the book of Islam. Those are
meant not the is for the Jews. The Jews
are not Muslims and the Christians are
not Muslims.
>> Was Moses a Jew?
>> Moses. He's God sent him for the Jew.
But he was a Muslim. Same as Jesus. He
was a Muslim.
>> Was Moses?
>> Yes. No, he was a Muslim.
>> Hold on a second.
>> He's God sent him for Jew. Same as
Jesus. God sent him to
>> I understand. So you're saying, man, we
are getting a lot of quotes today. So
Moses and Jesus were not Jews.
>> They were Muslims. Same as Abraham and
Adam. I got you. So, Moses and Jesus
were not Jews. What What was the
ethnicity of Moses and Jesus? What What
What was their race?
>> Well, uh Jesus was born in Palestine.
>> Yeah. But what was his race?
>> Middle Eastern.
>> H
>> He was born in the Middle Eastern. In
Palestine.
>> Yeah. I'm not asking where they were
born. I'm asking what was their race.
What was the race of Moses and Jesus?
What was their ethnicity? This is what
happens when three scriptures in Islam
get corrupted.
>> No, but they were Muslims. Jesus was
born in in the
>> Do you talking about is Jew? Jesus is
Jew. Okay.
>> Jesus is a Jew. Okay. Got it.
>> Okay. Let me say that.
>> That's right. Jesus was a Jew. What
about Moses?
>> I don't know. I don't know Moses. I
don't remember.
>> Moses was also a Jew.
>> Okay. So, were you into a Jew if you're
Jewish? If you're Were you a Christian?
race, brother. That's an ethnicity.
>> Yeah. If Jesus was Jew, why are you a
Christian? Why you are not Jew?
>> Because Jesus, the Jew, told me to
follow him, which means to be a
Christian, a Christ.
>> He was a Jew.
>> So, so to to bring this all around now.
So, Moses was a Jew. Jesus was a Jew. I
just wanted to make sure we got that
cleared up so far. Okay. And there are
scriptures that Allah gave them. Three
scriptures at least within Islam, within
the Islamic religion, three of the books
of Islam got corrupted. Therefore, Islam
is not trustworthy. Cuz remember we
said, and I agreed with you when I asked
you, remember I said, would you trust a
religion with corrupted scripture? You
said no. Well, Islam has at least three
corrupted scriptures. So therefore,
Islam is not trustworthy.
>> Well, are you you're a Christian, right?
>> Huh?
>> Are you were you trusting a religion? Is
it that is also uh corrupt?
>> Well, we could get to whether I do or
not in a second.
>> He said also. Yeah, also. So, so you're
agreeing that you follow a religion that
is untrustworthy and that has corrupt
description. You agree?
>> You didn't let me finish my question.
>> Well, you you said al you said that I
also am following a religion.
>> No, why said why?
>> Yeah. Why? You said why am I also
following a religion with corrupt
description? Which means you're you're
acknowledging that you do too.
>> No, if you if you No, what I mean is if
you tell me that I have a corrupted
religion, why you also believe in an
corrupted religion?
>> I didn't tell you that you have a
corrupted religion. You said it. You
admitted that you have a corrupted
religion. You
>> No, I did not.
>> Didn't you tell me that three books of
Islam got corrupted?
>> By who? It's not by God. It by human.
>> No worries. No, it could have been by a
fish or maybe by a goat who ate a page.
Who knows?
>> Yes.
>> It m no matter how it got corrupted,
>> three of the books of Islam got
corrupted, right?
>> But what happened when these books are
being corrupted?
>> Is that correct?
>> Yes.
>> Okay. So, notice notice how you said
yes. So, you're telling me, not me.
You're admitting that Islam is full of
corruption. It has three books that are
corrupted.
>> It had. But what happened after those
books? You know what happened?
>> What happened?
>> God revealed the Quran.
>> Why didn't the Quran being corrupted
too? If it's Islam, too.
>> Let me let me ask you this. I I brought
this uh this analogy up with the
previous caller. Let's say there was a
babysitter that you hired, a babysitter.
>> Okay. The babysitter got hired to watch
four kids. Okay. The first kid got unal
alived. It ended up dying under her
watch. The second kid got lost in a
forest on a camping trip under her
watch. The third kid was starved and
malnourished, had no food and water, was
not taken care of physically. But the
fourth kid, she took very care very well
care of. She took good care of took good
care of that fourth kid, you know, fed
him, kept them alive, kept them safe,
didn't get lost, right? Would you say
that that babysitter is trustworthy
since they've since she took care of the
fourth kid but lost the first three and
didn't take didn't take care of the
first three?
>> Is that the only example that you could
find comparing religion to a babysitter?
We're talking about God.
>> That's the best example that I can find
right now. What do What do you think? Is
that Is that babysitter Is that
babysitter trustworthy? When they take
good care of the fourth kid, but the
first three kids, she did not take good
care of them. Is that babysitter
trustworthy?
>> You got to find a good example, man. Is
we talking about God? You talking about
uh babysitter?
>> What do you Here, here, answer this.
Would you hire that babysitter?
>> The person No.
>> Why not?
>> If you What do you mean? No. Why not?
>> Yeah. Why not?
>> Okay. Give I'll give you this. If that
if you hire you you were hiring this
maid. How do you know that? That's what
happened.
>> Why wouldn't you hire that babysitter?
Dude, just answer the question if you
can. Pretty please.
>> I can't cuz the answer may give you I
give I say I I don't hire her because
you found a as a weak example. You
managed to find only books I uh could
help you. I can find an I can find an
example but that make sense
>> my brother you said that you would not
hire that particular babysitter.
>> Yes.
>> Why not?
>> Why nothing happened to the fourth kid?
>> Because she took good care of the fourth
kid.
>> Why would she make
>> Why wouldn't you hire her, dude? Answer
the question.
>> Maybe maybe because she didn't do the
right job with the other kids.
>> Ah, see how you see how easy that was?
No, you're talking about maid now.
That's
>> It's okay. So, you wouldn't hire that
babysitter.
>> Yes.
>> Because she has a history of not doing a
good job with the other kids.
>> Why would she make a good job then with
the fourth kid?
>> Exactly. You can't even with the fourth
kid, right?
>> No. No. But she you said she did a good
good job with the four. Why
>> she did? So even though even though she
did a good job with the fourth kid, you
still wouldn't hire her. You still
wouldn't
>> you still wouldn't trust her.
>> No, but why why she make exa exception?
>> Doesn't matter. It doesn't matter.
>> No, it doesn't matter because
>> maybe she just decided to pick up on her
game and
>> Exactly. That's why
she But she's still not trustworthy,
though.
>> You still Exactly. what you're what
you're trying to do. You're saying,
"Hey, she did a good job, but even I
still won't trust her." That's the
point. That's the reason why when you
guys say the Quran is not corrupted, but
everything else is. Your religion is
still untrustworthy. That's you're not
putting two and two together. You can
tell us how well she did on the last
child. It doesn't matter. You, me,
logic, everybody in this chat who has a
brain will not trust her because her
track record. That's the point. Is that
mean that the that the Bible is also
corrupted? Because let's say one of the
kids is the is the Bible.
>> Don't go to the Bible yet, man. We could
get to it. It's one of the kids then if
the Bible it's one of them.
>> Oh, the B Oh, so the Bible is one of
them. The Bible is one of the revealed
revelations.
>> Example you gave me.
>> So give me the example.
>> Just be clear. The Bible is a revelation
from a law that got corrupted.
>> Wait, let's see how you put it with the
I didn't put the example. You did.
>> Thank you for coming, brother. You
didn't pick your example. You You did.
You You did, Elijah. You made him say
everything he said today. You You This
ain't nothing he said. This is what you
forced him to say. That's how they do,
man. It's It's embarrassing.
>> Islam. And notice when I brought these,
I only use this example twice today. And
each time the Muslims said, "It's not a
good example. It doesn't make sense."
You want to know why, guys? Because it
makes perfect sense. because it's a
perfect example. If you wouldn't trust a
babysitter who failed with the first
three kids but did good with the fourth,
you wouldn't pay her. You wouldn't hire
her. Matter of fact, you might call the
police on her and say, "That one needs
to be arrested."
>> Mhm.
>> You need her license taken away.
>> Need her her license taken away. The
same way you wouldn't trust that
babysitter is the same way that any
thinking person like life said, any
thinking person in this chat would not
trust Allah who's supposed to be the
babysitter of his scriptures. Don't
Islam guys, Islam does this to you. You
say your shahada, that's what it does to
you. You do your daily prayers, that's
what it does to you. You go fast on
Ramadan, that's what it does to you. You
go do your Hajj, that's what it does to
you. It makes you tarded re man.
>> Gota stay away from all that stuff man.
My goodness. All that all that
repetitive foolishness. Oh the Quran is
true because it's true. Repetitiveness.
Just saying the same thing over and over
again. Not critically thinking. You
going to end up like these people that
come up on stage man can make sense of a
very simple question.
>> Hypocritical religion.
>> It's no. It's no.
>> It's no.
>> You maybe. Yeah. Yeah. Probably. Yep.
We're about to read a couple super
chats. Got a lot to get through, man.
But not I'm not I'm not going to read a
whole bunch right now. Just try to break
it up. Um let's see here. Okay. Yeah.
What you what you said? Well, basically
same standard goes for all the
religions, right? They all have to pass
the test. Absolutely.
>> Yeah. Yeah. For example, if you're going
to deny miracle, you have to deny
miracle for all the relig.
>> For all religions. Yeah.
>> Or Yeah. Have to be the the the
layground have to be the same for all. I
agree on it.
>> Would you uh would you trust a religion
that has corrupted scripture?
>> Corrupted scripture? No,
>> I wouldn't either. I agree. I have that
I have that same standard. Within Islam,
you you believe that Allah revealed the
Torah, the Psalms, the Gospel, and the
Quran. Is that correct that these are
all books of Islam?
>> These are
>> books of Islam. I don't know what you
mean by these are the Christian.
>> Yeah. But Allah like Allah revealed
these books. He revealed the Torah. He
revealed the Psalms. He revealed the
Gospel. Yes, of course. The only true
God. Yes. Whatever you can call him,
call him Allah, Allah, God.
>> Let's just stick with Allah. We'll stick
with Allah. And so, so, yeah. So, Allah
revealed all these books, right? And so,
all of these books you would say are
within the religion of Islam. Would you
agree?
>> Yes. Yes. Now, just before you continue,
you have a problem with saying, "So, you
say Allah or Allah?"
>> Just Allah, bro, cuz that's how you know
him. That's it's no problem. It's
>> No, no. How How you know him? You don't
know him as Allah? It's it's Allah in
Islam. So that's how we're sticking with
I don't I don't want to I don't want to
strong minded. This is such a
>> No. Unless you are unless you are
>> strong minded, please. That is such a
red herring. Like it's a rabbit trail
that literally matters not to our
conversation. Let's please stay focused.
>> No, it matters because I'm talking to a
Christian.
>> Can you stay focused for the
conversation? Strong mind.
>> No, I don't talk with an atheist at all.
>> Yeah. Okay.
>> We don't share beliefs. So I I cannot
talk with an atheist.
>> Yeah, I'm a Christian. So
>> you're a Christian?
>> Yeah, I'm a Christian. So So you So you
believe So you So you believe that all
of these books You believe all of these
books are books of Islam, correct?
>> Not books of I don't know what you mean
by Islam.
>> How how many religions does Allah have?
How many religions did Allah reveal?
>> I don't know. What do you mean by Allah?
You mean the only true God?
>> If you're going to play game If you're
going to play games, you can go. Take
care of yourself. Get off the stage.
>> I don't know what you mean by Allah,
bro. What is What are we doing, bro? I
don't know what I mean by Allah. Wow.
That's okay. My gosh.
>> Edward, how you doing? You Muslim?
>> Alhamdulillah.
>> Why do you keep coming to my stage, bro?
>> I don't. I come once every 50 years.
>> Yeah. Why do you keep coming every once
every 50 years? Why do you keep coming?
>> To discuss.
>> But if if you immediately get kicked all
the time, that shows that I don't want
to discuss with you. Why do you keep
coming? Come to law.
>> That was the perfect answer, man.
>> Five dailies, man.
>> Five day. Hey, that's that masjid
behavior, man. Mid behavior. Five didn't
play your